(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] M.C. Escher
has nothing on this place.
Chand Baori is one of
the largest and perhaps
most visually spectacular stepwells.
(upbeat music)
This deep, four-sided
structure is made up of 3,500
Escher-esque terrace
steps that descend down
to a depth of 100 feet.
A large temple adorns the face
dedicated to Harshat Mata,
goddess of joy and happiness.
You may recognize this incredible wonder.
Its intricate steps have
made appearances in Hollywood
films like The Fall,
The Dark Knight Rises
and The Best Exotic Marigold Hotel.
Northwestern India,
where the stepwell lies,
is extremely arid.
The well was designed to conserve
as much water as possible.
At the bottom of the well,
the air remains five degrees
cooler than at the surface,
making it an excellent gathering
place for locals during
intense heat waves.
(upbeat music)